peace be with you welcome to the dean
show me your host and my next guest john
fontaine
who was on a jazz tour most of his life
he was imitating the likes of tony
bennett frank sinatra was on the same
card as winston marcellus
some of the the jazz legends we're gonna
be talking to him we're also gonna be
talking about christmas it's that time
of the year people are getting jolly
spending a lot of money having a lot of
fun so we're gonna be really digging
deep into christmas and also i'm talking
about paul walker
tyrese gibson
and ufc champion gsp we got another
message for him all of this and more
here on the dean's show
any relation to johnny fontaine from the
godfather movie was that the jazz singer
in that movie well this was the
character which i was named after in my
singing career
so uh
yeah because i used to sing jazz music
so from a young age people was calling
me johnny fontaine and eventually became
john fontaine yeah so a lot of people
know me by this name so you were on a
you you were trying to imitate the likes
of tony bennett you've actually met tony
bennett and you were on the car same
card as some of the uh
jazz celebrities like uh winston
marcellus and winston marcellus and um
same venues
so you mix with a lot of the the uh
great uh jazz musicians out there yeah
this was your life yeah my life for over
eight years yeah i was singing in cruise
ships jazz clubs
football stadiums yeah touring the world
touring the world yeah so tell us how
how did you how did you end up we're
going to actually we're not going to get
we want to get people excited also we're
going to go more detail to your
story but just kind of giving people
some of the highlights that you were one
who was you know out there mixing with
celebrities you were living that life
you were trying to be a star you're
reaching for the stars wasn't it right
well it's a way to be you know
a famous jazz singer you know wanted to
be successful in my career do you feel
like that's what a lot of people not
only do they emulate a lot of these
celebrities but they they want to if
you're emulating them you want it most
likely you want to be like them you want
to be you want to be a star of course
yeah yeah and i mean this is like uh
really at the end uh i mentioned that we
were going to be talking about paul
walker also was celebrity fast furious
do you know anything about him yeah
again he's you know he's done he's very
successful in his career you know done
many movies
and uh he had a sad end unfortunately
yeah so you know the reason i'm i bring
up
people like himself is because people
idolize them they look up to him they
line up to watch their films but this
was an individual who had hopes and
ambitions
you know beyond today i mean for years
they're already planning for a new film
to come out but then deaf
sneaks up and you never know when it's
going to come so people usually they
avoid talking about the purpose of life
and the whole theme behind the dean's
show is we want to encourage people to
really think beyond behind the
materialism think behind money and fame
as you
got to really thinking beyond that and
now
you know you've you've uh changed your
whole life around for the better
yeah i mean this is what happens i mean
it's one thing that we're certain of is
death you know but we get caught up in
the material world you know we're
chasing our dreams chasing money
or whatever it may be and we forget to
ask the question what is the purpose of
life
definitely did you have you did you ever
get a chance to watch this uh fast and
furious
um
i think i may have seen it i can't
remember yeah but can you imagine i mean
i i also i trained uh martial arts the
uh gracie brazilian jutsu and he was
actually also someone who was involved
in gracie brazilian jiu jitsu
so he was athletic
he was someone who was a movie star
people idolize him but that's it when
that moment comes
i mean i had an experience like this
myself
three years ago i actually collapsed on
the floor
and i found out i had a brain tumor
and
alhamdulillah two years ago i had it
removed successfully removed
um but if it
i mean at the time my non-muslim family
was you know they was devastated you
know because they didn't have any faith
in god
you know but because i was a muslim
i it didn't affect me at all you know
because we we know where you know we
know about the the hereafter and the
purpose of life and this helped me
uh in this calamity
now you want you mentioned muslim and
obviously a muslim is one who just like
jesus and all the other messengers that
the creator sent muslim is one who
submits not to his desires or a man or
woman or anything christian but to the
creator and you weren't always a muslim
were you no
i mean i was i was brought up in a
christian background so i was actually a
christian i used to play we'll go into
that in more depth in the other story i
think yeah but we'll just give us some
some uh snippets yeah i mean i was
brought up as a christian i was very
active in the church i used to play the
church organ
and
eventually started looking into islam
many things led
to me to look into islam and
finally i came to the conclusion that
islam is the truth and the quran is the
final revelation there's somebody out
there who's like man this they've got uh
you know white arabs or like
you know maybe pakistani are you asian
or
arab or pakistani i'm actually from
manchester england manchester england
yes so my grandparents are from ireland
ireland and well some of my grandparents
so you're irish one side of the family's
irish yeah and the other side is english
so uh well i'm born and bred in
manchester yeah yeah so you might have
heard of manchester united yeah so this
is the thing yeah uh
tell me that's amazing now because
there's a lot of stereotypes obviously
that people think okay if you're a
muslim you're an arab
you know maybe you're you're indo-pak
but you're irish
top of the morning to you right is that
how they say it
english irish english irish
are there a lot of uh you know people
who are god conscious who are muslim who
have have turned their life towards the
same directions you've turned your life
in in this part of the world yeah i mean
since accepting islam i've been active
in dawa which is conveying the message
inviting people towards islam educating
people about islam alhamdulillah many
people are accepting islam and coming to
the truth
and
the same realization which i've had
which is that islam is the the correct
way of life now how do you you know and
we'll go more into detail when we talk
about your story but there's a
fascinating clip out there it's from a
brother also he's i believe
correct me if i'm wrong but i think he's
hispanic he's in australia
and he's doing some wonderful work he
does this spoken word yes right and he
did a very very uh um wonderful video
talking about the uh meaning of life
have you heard of this uh tyrese gibson
yes tyrese gibson is also like a very uh
good friend with paul walker
and he tweeted actually his video saying
that this gave me life
that's amazing isn't it i've seen the
video almost
we're gonna go to a clip of it right now
so people who haven't seen it will just
go ahead for 30 seconds you can see it
right here
then just turn up the radio as you learn
to live a lifestyle of drugs sex and
rock and roll
but in all honesty i just need to know
is there more to the cycle than growing
and getting old living and dying just to
leave behind a happy home and a whole
lot of property that somebody else is
going to own
i just really need to know before the
caskets closed cuz i'm not willing to
gamble with my soul nor am i ready to
take any chances these are just simple
life questions and i'm just searching
for some answers
like what are we doing here
and what is our purpose
how did we get here and who made us so
perfect and what happens once we go or
is this world all really worth it
so in this clip
the brother goes into what most people
are doing with their life they're just
like robots just waking up for another
day another dollar like zombies being
entertained music movies following their
desires were you kind of living the same
life yeah i mean it was just one gig
after another
you know and the saying is you're only
as good as your last gig you know you
you're only as good as your last job
because
you you're constantly chasing you're
chasing the the world you're chasing the
dunya
the material life
and you're never going to get there
you know we see this with many of the
stars or the the famous people in the
world
they have everything they have the money
they have the wealth they have the fame
but they're still not happy
i mean that's that's a fact that's not
fiction and people think like okay if i
achieve this stardom i'm gonna be like
just in a world of bliss but they're
some of the most
miserable people
you know unhappy why are you taking
drugs if you are happy yeah it's it's
it's amazing so
before we get into also we want to it's
that time of the year that you know
santa claus is supposed to be coming and
the gifts and he's coming down this
man's coming down the chimney were you
at one point in your life waiting for
the big uh big guy to come to the the
the santa claus to with the uh you know
the big guy come down the chimney of
course you were taught this yeah i i i
believed in father christmas it's
probably my first belief yeah you know
we taught uh from a very young age that
father christmas is
is is real and it's a reality
you know we're um
we we leave the we
we taught this from a very young age you
know we leave like gifts like food mince
pies and a glass of wine for father
christmas we come down in the morning
and it's been eaten you know this
enforces the belief yeah uh you know we
come down in his presence under the tree
and this is real you know we it was if
the presence just appeared
you know but unfortunately well it
wasn't real it wasn't real yeah and
that's the that's that's the thing that
the
that limelight of a lifestyle is made
to
perceive happiness and like that's real
but that's that fake life right
and you were living it as a jazz singer
musician he said you're only as good as
your last gig yeah
that's you living for that moment yeah
that moment yeah but then what i mean
when the when the when the uh
the people are gone and you're by
yourself there's no one else to you know
be holding you up high and
there's actually some
i've seen recently online some tweets
uh from uh branford marcellus he's a
famous uh uh jazz
uh saxophonist yeah and he was also
saying
that he he was disappointed he was going
to certain places in the world and
people didn't recognize him
you know he actually thought he was more
famous than he actually was yeah so he
was like they don't know me yeah
and he's the sense of disappointment in
his tweet that that's that ego now right
so people living for the ego we got a
lot more to talk about more on christmas
and
you know some of these more important
topics so don't go nowhere we'll be
right back with john fontaine here on
the dean's show questions we don't
answer because apparently we don't
really have to there's no purpose to
this life and our existence is merely
natural then in that case please let me
ask you did you create yourself or was
it somebody else who had fashioned you
cause you're a being that's impeccable
faultless and unparalleled you're a
product of supreme intelligence and i'm
merely being rational
for there isn't a camera on this earth
that can come close to the human eye nor
a computer that can compete alongside
the human mind and if the whole world
was to come together we wouldn't be able
to create a single fly
so many signs yet we
still deny
jihad often mistranslated as holy war
the word jihad means to struggle
islam does not preach violence it does
not preach vicious holy war it certainly
does not condone terror and suicide
bombing
islam preaches compassion tolerance and
justice find the truth about islam
call toll free 877 why islam order your
free copy of the quran today back here
on the dean show with john fontaine
who was
shooting for the stars
and that's what many people nowadays in
one way or another they they want that
status they want to be
loved and they seek love i mean most of
us you know love is not obviously a bad
thing but when you seek it just in the
creation
you know and you don't you give your
heart
away you know you sell it and many
people sell in their souls and you give
your heart away and and instead of
taking it and giving it to the to the
maker
to the one who created you that that
becomes a real big problem isn't it yeah
they come as slaves to their desires
instead of a servant and a slave to the
creator now some people say okay what do
you mean a servant slaven to the creator
let's go into that because jesus peace
be upon him
you know he was one who didn't submit
to anyone other than the one who made
him the creator right so he was a slave
and a servant and this is the same thing
that you're talking about this is what a
muslim is correct yeah and if if if we
look at prophet abraham uh you can say
the father of all the three major faiths
judaism christianity and islam
uh prophet abraham peace be upon him he
was going uh through the same thing you
know he he i mean prophet abraham wasn't
christian or jewish
you know he came before christianity and
judaism but he submitted to the one
creator you know and and the arabic term
for this is a muslim that's it and we
believe all the prophets and messengers
were muslim are people who submit their
will to the creator of the universe and
that's the big problem i think that we
have today is that people just blindly
following customs and cultures and this
is one of those that we are going to be
talking about now a little bit more is
christmas
so you were celebrating it and you were
doing the things that people do and do
you still celebrate it no i don't
i mean we when i was younger we would i
mean christmas was more of a
a traditional thing rather than a
religious festival uh in england
uh we we would just look forward to the
presence and the and the turkey yeah you
know it was uh it was a time for coming
together coming together with the
family but
the thing with with christmas is
the that when we're taught to believe in
father christmas you know that when as
children you know we would the the
father christmas would come to the
school we would sit on his knee we would
tell him what we would like for
christmas and ultimately he would you
know we knew that if we was good if he
was well behaved then we would get our
gift so we was actually
um
if you like uh
accountable to father christmas instead
of being accountable to your maker to
the creator yeah so we was accountable
to father christmas and throughout the
year our parents would say
if you're not good we'll tell father
christmas you know and that's upon allah
you know
you can see actually father christmas
becoming like a god next to god in a god
in next to god and if we look at in that
sense father christmas it's a
metaphorical father he's not our real
father and we can see throughout other
religions including christianity and we
have this similar thing happening where
we have the father yeah you know and
things like this so when i opened up the
show and i mentioned people such as paul
walker the famous movie star fast and
furious and then tyrese gibson who
actually tweeted that this gave this
this um
video this meaning of life it gave me
life because it you know when you look
into islam islam is not something and
you find obviously the same thing
because it's not blind belief you didn't
come at this just blindly you had to
make some really big sacrifices being a
former christian and now you were
investigating you were using the
faculties that the creator gave you
didn't you to realize that to come to
the reason the realization that this is
really indeed from the creator i mean
allah tells us in the quran we're not
allowed
to just follow blindly you know he tells
us bring your proof if your truth bring
your proof yeah and this is not just for
non-believers this is also for muslims
you know many muslims they follow
they say they're muslim because their
parents are muslim you know this is not
acceptable we need to know why we're a
muslim you know and and allah encourages
us to do encourages us to do this in the
quran by looking for the proof now
you're also an author of a book called
jesus and the injil yes you mentioned
allah in your book you talk about the
name jesus peace be upon him what did he
call
allah by god
yeah well the i mean most likely jesus
spoke aramaic
and that our main word for god is allah
you know we know the arabic word for god
the arabic name the god is allah allah
yeah so and then in hebrew it's
elohim elohim he's many
this is the one god the one true god
yeah did jesus ever ever in his life
call people to worship him to take him
as a
god or some people say okay we don't
believe in him as god but he's god's son
okay no jesus never uh called people to
to worship himself he always uh he came
with the true message which was to
worship
allah worship god the creator you have
no other gods
and do do people like because now that
you're a muslim do you feel you love
jesus more yeah i mean we we follow
jesus and respect jesus we love jesus uh
a lot more than previously
and in your book you talk about and you
give the evidences and proves that he
was known as a prophet
that uh people didn't call
obviously that he was subordinate yes he
wasn't
with god
god but you give the evidence from the
bible that he was actually subordinate
to god that he was one
a slave to god yeah he was a slave to
god and a messenger and he actually
received a message from god yeah and we
actually give the evidence within the
book to show that like the other
prophets like moses and and david they
also received revelation from god jesus
also received a revelation yeah called
the injure uh what do you now and
obviously we're not trying to bash
christianity or or or disparage as i say
on anybody we're just trying to
enlighten people people to think and not
blindly
just you know follow just to really
think
for yourself and to really do like you
did and you investigated these things
what were you going to say i was going
to say uh i mean
chris uh christmas is you would say a
christian uh festival
and the
prophet abraham again if we come to the
story of prophet abraham he also
questioned what his forefathers were
doing abraham the prophet abraham he you
know his his forefathers were worshiping
an idol there was worshipping idols they
was believing in idols they was they was
asking idols and worshipping idols and
and prophet abraham peace be upon him
questioned this and when he found it to
be false
he he corrected his he or he tried to
correct
his forefathers because he was searching
for the proof he wasn't just blindly
following so we should all
take this lesson from prophet abraham
peace be upon him what made you
do that same thing because that's what
you got to do you got to not blindly
imitate
but you have to think for yourself and
really reflect and at what point in your
life did you start doing that
my first memory of uh coming to the
realization and as i say it's very
similar to the father christmas moment
because anyone who's believed in father
christmas
will remember the point that the exact
place they were when they found out i
don't know if you remember
but when i remember exactly where i was
when i found out father christmas wasn't
real and this happened also when i was
in church because he was asked to write
a song about jesus
and my son was jesus and god
and i remember the the vicar coming over
grabbing the piece of paper and
scribbling it out
and writing jesus is god
and from this moment from a very young
age maybe the the age of about eight
years old this didn't fit with me and
this is when i began to question uh my
belief and start to look at other other
ways as well so you're in the church
okay and you're you're told to write a
song and you and you wrote jesus and god
yeah jesus and who came now and the past
the victor the vicar came what is it
called the vicar vicar is like what is
that the pastor
he's like the pastor yeah yeah
in england in england we call him the
vicar vicar yeah vicar for the church of
england so he he saw your song and he
said no he's yeah he scribbles it he
screamed with myself yeah and he said no
jesus is god yeah and this didn't make
sense you know my my fitzra my inner
self was telling me this this is not
the correct belief because obviously
jesus peace be upon him who we love no
muslim is a muslim unless you believe
and love jesus that he was the messiah
is that right that he was born of um the
immaculate conception and name some of
these other things yeah i mean the the
similarities uh between the christian
view of jesus and the muslim view are
many you know have jesus himself
causing it refers to himself as a
prophet within the bible
he has his miraculous birth so the
virgin mary
and even
even the the virgin mary uh
in in this in the sight of islam we
we have hadith which which speak of mary
is the most pious woman to ever lived at
that time you know and even in the quran
itself we have a whole chapter called
surah mary chapter mary in the verbatim
what have we got the quran this is
amazing many people don't know these
facts and when they tune in and they get
to see people such as yourself irish uh
you know people who are just white
you're white you're not uh brown dark i
mean but people from from all walks of
life to the black and the white
obviously there's no racism in islam
where one humanity and islam brings us
truly together so when they really get
to see someone like you you know and
who's also a former christian celebrated
christmas but then you start to really
think and not blindly follow and you
came to the realization that jesus is
not god no man is god god is god we're
the creation of god we need to submit to
god yeah that's what you did yeah
exactly that's what i did and
in in doing so uh even if we look again
at the the tradition of father christmas
why do we do this we have to question
why do we do it let's hold off right
there the same thing we gotta go to
break so hold your place why do we do
this we're gonna answer that question
here with john fontaine
zero plus zero plus zero cannot possibly
ever give you one
so from where did all this order come
for everything has its origins a maker a
creator of its own i mean the only
reason you're watching this video is
because somebody had to press upload so
we can believe in the big bang but i'd
rather believe in he who caused it to
explode
allah
the creator of everything i am not
afraid to stand alone
i am not afraid to stand alone if allah
afraid to is alone if allah is by
messiah i am not afraid to stand alone
i am not afraid to stand alone if allah
is
back here on the dean show with former
jazz
singer
was touring all over was it all over uk
or all over the world all over the world
you're really into music yeah yeah
you was yeah yeah you were you gave it
all up
and and
why do you think people do they what you
did i mean you found solace at that
point did you find solace like you know
contentment of music or it was just
momentary entertainment and then all
that wears off and then then again
you're bored and you're looking for
excitement it's not enduring like like
islam you have you truly find that peace
it's all temporary it's temporary
fulfillment yeah yeah and you you really
couldn't get no i mean
why do you think people just keep going
and going and they just keep hitting the
dead end and the dead end in the dead
end they're constantly trying to fill
that void in themselves did you fill
that void with islam yeah masha'allah so
continue on you said okay why do people
with the christmas yes
it's important to look at what we do and
question why we do it
and if you if you look at the lessons we
learn from believing in father christmas
i mean why would you lie to your
children
you know
that father christmas is real people
might say oh because it makes it fun
people people might say because it makes
it fun
but
many children are scared of father
christmas
you know and
it's uh the lessons we learn from it is
that it's okay to lie and that you can't
even trust your own parents
and if you can't trust your own parents
who can you trust and we have to we
ultimately have to ask the question is
it possible we've been lied to within
our own belief such as if we follow uh
religion we have to ask the question is
it possible we've been lied to with that
and is this where we can see how things
build up we've been lied to about the
the um
santa claus
the two fairy and now jesus being a
literal son of god yeah people being
lied to about that too isn't it yeah
yeah i mean and then people just leave
religion all together and become
atheists this is the problem uh people
because christianity didn't make sense
to them they ultimate this is what
happened to me i i gave up religion i i
still had the belief in something belief
in the creator but i gave up
religion because i knew that i'd been
lied to with religion
and it was i couldn't find uh anything
to to base my proof on therefore i just
left religion and just carried on
believing i've had this belief inside of
the creator but i left religion many
people
go to the extreme of now denying this a
creator
and other people
stick with christianity or stick with
their belief but they choose to follow
it even though they don't have proof
yeah amazing
you find many many christians today uh
they follow christianity blindly yeah
even though they know that we don't have
any any evidence for it we had a french
brother on the show and we took that
opportunity to invite the ultimate
fighting championship um
gsp uh george st pierre he gave him a
beautiful message to george yeah he is a
he gave him a beautiful message
and and we have this clip we want to
share with with uh the audience and then
get your your thoughts on it
i can i can't sleep at night now i'm i'm
going crazy i had these shoes man i uh
and i need to relax i need to get out
for a while you know
i'm
i don't know what i'm gonna do i mean i
am
i'm i feel like i'm gonna laugh
everything out now but i have to keep
some of my stuff some of part of my life
personally okay you got to hear that
yeah i can't sleep at night i'm going
crazy i can't i can't sleep at night now
i'm i'm going crazy can you relate to
that were there sleepless nights in your
career
when you were at your top but you still
that void was so heavy like right now
he's at the top
but he's going crazy he can't sleep can
you relate to what he's saying
in a sense yes because
he's chasing what's he chasing now
because i've not got to the peak where i
wanted to be i'm constantly chasing but
now he's reached that peak
you know he he's
he's the champion
what now
and now he he doesn't know where to go
he's lost you cannot buy peace i always
say it this is what i've said in the
past you cannot buy a six-pack a piece
peace is something that comes from who
the creator the creator the maker the
one who made you so how what advice
would you give for him and and other
people now like uh therese
who actually the one who tweeted this uh
meaning of life who's obviously that got
him thinking so but there's a lot of
negative stereotypes associated with
islam so there's confusion what do you
what do you advise people i mean there's
actually a team uh well there's a
brother in england uh
he um
called imran mansour and he actually
invites the celebrities to islam
this this is this is what he focuses on
yeah and and he actually contacts them
and many of them
uh are actually now starting to look in
islam yeah look look look towards islam
and
that's the only option that's it that is
the only option where are you going to
go
i mean you're going to keep you know
going and following your desires and
there's no happiness there i mean the
thing is they come to the reality they
have all the money the wealth the fame
and they can't leave the house yeah
you know all the friends around them
they can't trust anyone
you know it's it's not a nice place to
be in but with islam subhanallah you go
to mecca for hajj
and you all wearing the same clothes you
know the same two sheets and you're
performing the rich the rituals of hajj
and you don't know one person can be a
millionaire one person
can have no money yeah you know and it's
a beautiful thing and a good a good
thing to actually read is the biography
of malcolm x and he speaks about this
when he actually went to hajj and he was
sitting with millionaires and poor
people they all wearing the same thing
eating them from the same pot white
black subhanallah
so purpose of life that's the crucial
question and do you believe
that i mean that if you just take that
simple step that you ask your maker to
guide you that he'll guide you
yes i i advise this a lot uh so for
people who are searching put your head
on the floor
in the in the in the state of
prostration like all the prophets did
and ask the creator of the universe to
show you the way to guide you to the
straight path
and someone who sincerely asked for
guidance
subhanallah they'll find it in islam
that's it like you did you know and so
many i mean people it's the fastest
growing way of life in the world uh
today yesterday and tomorrow it's it's
growing because it has a believable
message and it's based on proof and
evidence not blind faith is that right
of course yeah so we got to go uh god
willing we'll have you back on the
program again people you have the new
book called the injil jesus jesus and
uh where can people pick this up uh it's
on jesus.com
you can order the booklet from there the
book is coming soon beautiful beautiful
thank you very much
oh yeah i look forward to having you
back again
and thank you for tuning in to the dean
show
and the fact the reality is that
just like paul walker
and
so many others
we come into this world we live it and
then we die and in between was
where we just created in just and in
play and in amusement
entertainment is not going to bring you
happiness it's temporary fun and
amusement but the true happiness comes
when you're living your true purpose of
life and why you've been created
so are you going to continue going
through life being entertained or
entertaining people
and not living your purpose
and then when you die
and you face the ultimate reality
paradise is on one hand and hellfire is
on the other and you didn't prepare
yourself for the eternal life of
paradise that jesus called his people to
moses abraham and the last and the final
mission of prophet muhammad peace be
upon him they all gave the good news
that if you obey your creator
you do good you live a good righteous
life you're going to make mistakes but
you turn humbly and you repent only to
the creator no intermediaries between
you and god worshiping the creator not
the creation that makes sense but you
gotta want it you wanted that ufc belt
and you went for it you wanted that
money that girl that man and you went
for it you cried for it
you sweat for it but what about your
maker how much time are you putting in
to seek him out have you once asked
my maker my creator guide me have you
done it once
do it twice three times
put your head on the floor like john
fontaine
gave you that beautiful advice do that
right now before we leave and see what
happens and start to explore really look
beyond the material
satisfactions that are temporary and
paradise that's forever but you got to
pass the test of this life first to
attain
that
so we hope that you got to benefit
purpose of life that's really what you
should be contemplating and thinking
about and then build everything else on
that follow us
on twitter like us on facebook and keep
us keep up with us every week we got a
new show we're talking about serious
topics
topics that would change your life and
your world for the better we'll see you
next time until then
peace be with you
you